before my talk at the table um i have
something that you're seeing first on
cbs mornings we're revealing bon
appetit's new list of best new
restaurants of 2022 it will be published
in their october issue the list is a
decades-long tradition for bon appetit
staff members travel the country
sampling foods at new eateries talk
about a dream job get a place on this
lineup it can make a big difference for
the restaurants now before we reveal
this year's picks let's take a look at
what goes into making the list and what
it means to be on it
every year there's an enormous
responsibility you want to get it right
you want to make sure
that the restaurants you choose really
represent the best and the most exciting
right now and i think
now more than ever we're thinking about
not just oh is this food delicious but
what is the vibe of this place how are
the people that are working here
feeling
you really really get a sense that for a
lot of new restaurants being recognized
in this way and feeling seen in this way
by a publication like bon appetit is
such a gratifying moment being in the
hot 10 it forever changed kindred it
does bring in a lot of customers it went
from like 20 000 a week to like 60 000 a
week like that but it also is this
moment where a chef or a sommelier or a
restaurant owner gets to step back and
realize what an amazing thing they've
done
[Music]
it pushed me as a chef
it made me want to be better there's a
lot of power in that list you start with
the chef is the chef doing something
that feels true to them we're trying to
introduce people to live ocean food
understanding that this is what we grew
up with our mom and grandma take this
type of food for us all food is culture
and all culture is history true essence
of southeast asian laos cuisine is is
making things from scratch and so i
think there's just so much more that
goes into a restaurant than you might
expect from first walking in and i think
all of that goes into choosing a
restaurant and knowing it's one of the
best new restaurants in the country
bon appetit's list of best new
restaurants this year includes in no
particular order
supper land in charlotte north carolina
it's described as southern steakhouse
meets church potluck oh sign me up cafe
mutton in hudson new york um which uses
meats and vegetables from local farmers
and foragers and republica in portland
oregon which honors mexican heritage don
davis is editor-in-chief for bon appetit
good morning how are you doing good
morning thank you okay so you're saying
that supper land is worth a trip to
charlotte north carolina absolutely as
you mentioned it's a steakhouse meets a
potluck church potluck it's in a
mid-century old church it's got a
speakeasy and a champagne bar i have
made the miso mac and cheese my mother
happened to be visiting and this is a
woman who never changes the thanksgiving
menu and she's putting it on the
thanksgiving and mac and cheese is one
of those things that people don't adjust
people don't adjust but modern comfort
food that you can share with big parties
and it's super great atmosphere okay all
right cafe mutton in hudson new york
i've actually been there on a
recommendation of a friend before this
came out did you think eloise broke a
glass so i don't think i can go back
but they're changing the game you say it
was very good they're changing the game
the chef had been working in new york
city got tired of being told what to put
on the menu a grain bowl an avocado
toast and just followed her own
instincts she works with foragers and
farmers often using parts that other
people don't want and turns it into
magic stews makes her own pates she also
makes crepes by day
we have a recipe for the crepes in our
issue she also makes delicious muffins
so it's really kind of an all-day place
where you're going to trust the chef's
instincts you said there's a lot of
restaurants on the list don that you
described as what if restaurants what
does that mean kind of i think after the
pandemic the chefs had an opportunity to
rethink what they want to be post
pandemic so what if they could make
modern
comfort food that's korean and american
and one chef her adoptive father is
jewish so she also has korean and
american comfort food with a nod to uh
jewish food as well so really really
interesting combinations they're bold
republica did i say that right
republican
in portland oregon in portland oregon
why'd they make your list five taste
five course tasting menu under a hundred
dollars
paying homage to the food the indigenous
food of mexico
so think uh one course is with maize
they import it from century old farms
all over mexico and then kind of
transform it here in the states they
have a mescal tasting menu
and wines imported from mexico and i
think wines from mexico are really
underrated so a really special
experience there okay so you said you
made the miso mac and cheese on this
list there's recipes of places that you
may not be able to make it to but you
can actually make it yourself at home
exactly and we've adapted them for the
home cook we spent a lot of time in
making sure that these recipes are
obtainable and something that the home
cook could actually do if i can make the
miso mac and cheese anyone is that what
this pie is right here guys
we have a home cook yeah this is not me
by the way shout out to you supervising
producer i hope we didn't wrong you in
any way recently this is going to be a
good pie nothing in it now what is this
done this is the extremadura custard pie
it's from bocadillo market in chicago
one of our best 10. what i love about
bocadillo market is he fell in love
james martin fell in love with the food
of spain but he also wanted to pay
homage to the food from the american
south so
by day again you can get sandwiches
cafes pies this is a custard pie throws
my abs yeah and he puts a little bit of
gin or vodka in the crust so i think
that gives it a little kind of bounce
really good and almond flour and eggs
make this delicious custard really great
i would say some smiles no really good
dover did a really good job over nicely
done yeah i like that very good drawer
great i love the variety of the
restaurants on your list it's really
amazing um you should call it top ten
though kansas city missouri they got a
palestinian restaurant named baba's
baba's pantry terrific baba had been
working for other people for over 20
years in the food industry but his dream
was to have his own place and to bring
the food of palestine to the people in
kansas city and he did that some of the
best hummus with shredded beef or
shredded lamb if you like it's fantastic
and already you know we have a top 50
list and since it made that top 50 list
he's had to close for a couple days to
restock because people are loving it so
really melissa i like it i went from top
ten to just best restaurants yeah we
because it's the best way to we are all
foodies and we appreciate you coming don
davis you are the best i want to hear
from you about why you've seen some time
we changed it from hot to best because
after the pandemic we thought
restaurants had been through so much
right and it's not just about the hot
environment it's about the story it's
about the ambiance and ultimately it's
about the food and we thought these are
the best
of that
over you go this way all right it's not
like it's hip this is more than just hip
this is good really good
heart and delicious and for you at home
you can have the cbs mornings on your
favorite social media platform to get
the recipe for this pot and many others
bon appetit's october issue hits
newsstands next week
thank you